all right Walmart you've got some
explaining them I went to go buy it
print it cake from y'all the other day
did this image on no wouldn't do it I
got fruit I wouldn't do it yesterday
managed to get an Isis battle flag from
Isis happens to be of somebody who were
fighting against right now who are
killing our minim boys overseas and are
beheading Christians
that's a nice of battle flag cake then
anybody can go buy at Walmart which
can't bike okay
Confederate flag boy likes a ducha
hazards car the Walmart can you please
explain why you're alienating southern
Americans with this trash that you allow
to be sold in your store
you